Hey everyone. This is Jared, one of the creators
here at Wisecrack. With Halo 5 now on the shelves, we
thought there’s no better time to explore
some the more interesting things happening
under the surface of this blockbuster franchise.
So without further adieu, Welcome to this
episode on Identity and Religion in Halo.
Who is the master Chief? With more than sixty
five million game titles sold, it’s kind
of crazy that this question still remains
an enigma. But it is sort of THE reason to
play the game (beyond blowing up aliens and
riding around in warthogs). Master Chief is
often regarded as one of the top rated video
game characters of all time—but how is that
possible if we know so little about United
Nations Space Command, Master Chief Petty
Officer John-117?
I suppose the problem starts with a much more
complicated issue: Identity itself. One’s
identity is never cut and dry, easily understandable.
Identity is always messy, unclear, and ambiguous.
Not only is Master Chief’s mysterious because
we never see his face, there’s more: his
name is essentially a rank and number, and
also because he isn’t really alone in all
that armor.
As Master Chief’s AI, Cortana is your guide
through the Halo universe—she progresses
John through the game, explains most of the
story line, and is also a sort of quasi lover
for the Chief.
It might be possible to read HALO as a feminist
text by discussing the hybrid space created
by John and Cortana’s cyborg existence ala
Donna Harroway and her Cyborg Manifesto (Yes
that’s a real thing go look it up…
but Halo 4 pretty
much shits all over that possibility when
the message essentially becomes:.
Cortana is a damsel in distress, who as a
woman shouldn’t think too much because…
well… that is dangerous (Literally… Cortana’s
rampancy causes her to think her self… to
death).
Cortana flickering in Halo 4 during Rampancy—freaking
out.
But I guess the important thing is that everything
is resolved because she serves her man well.
Cortana’s entire story line is supposed
to be redeemed by getting to touch the chief
just once. Something about men in uniform,
am I right?
Perhaps identity in Halo can be best understood
through the lens of American Political Scientist
and Philosopher William Connolly. He describes
identity formation as a process of becoming—where
a person is taught and chooses how they wish
to be through an encounter with difference.
Essentially—people not only define themselves
by copying what is deemed cool or acceptable,
but also by distancing themselves from things
deemed unacceptable by society. It is through
this process of differentiating that people
form communities and self identify- whether
it be as a mother, son, queer, garbage man,
white, soldier, writer, gamer, etc.
Which brings us to the essential aspect that
permeates the narrative of Halo as well as
the second section of this video: fear of
the unknown, or as fancy philosophers like
to say: fear of “the other.”
It’s important to remember the historical
context surrounding Halo. Premiering in November
2001, it would perhaps be naïve to assume
that game is free of the ideological politics
of the time. Coming directly after the 9/11
attacks—Halo mirrors several elements of
the current war on terrorism.
I mean, for one-the Arbiter—a disgraced
warrior- is promised forgiveness and eternal
salvation if he accepts a suicide mission.
"You will die as each Arbiter has before you"
attacks or the fanaticism that
motivated the Oklahoma City bombing
At the heart of terrorism is fundamentalism—or
the belief that a particular creed or conviction
attacks or the fanaticism that
motivated the Oklahoma City bombing
At the heart of terrorism is fundamentalism—or
the belief that a particular creed or conviction
is objectively correct—and worth dying or
killing for.
It doesn't take too much digging to draw parallels between the Covenant and Fundamentalism.
A highly religious people guided by the teaching
of three prophets : Truth, Mercy,
and Regret, the Covenant are positioned as
the games antagonist—sort of cosmic religious
terrorists.
Religious dogmatism is essentially the guiding
force behind the conflict in the games. The
term “Covenant” itself is a reference
to a pact between a chosen people and their
god. The seven Halos rings are allusions to
the seven seals of the apocalypse and the
seven trumpet blasts that bring about the
end of the world.
The arch is a key component to activating
the Halo ring—which is in part a reference
to the covenant between Noah and God, as a
way to survive the great flood.
Knowing that the flood was an unstoppable
force—the forerunners created the arch and
the halo rings as a way to survive the flood…
get it? The arch is how you survive… the
flood.
Captain Keyes serves as a sort of John the
Baptist, Baptizing the Master Chief by giving
him his first gun… and also like John the
Baptist, Keyes loses his head.
Consider also the name we are given for the
Master Chief is John 117. John Book one verse
17 of the King James bible reads “For the
law was given by Moses, but Grace and Truth
came by Jesus Christ.” Just as Jesus gives
force to the law with his Eternal Grace, Master
Chief gives force to the law with his overpowered
pistol.
Given the multiple times that MC is resurrected
at the end of each Halo game it’s not too
much of a stretch to draw the comparison between
Master Chief and the big JC. Yes- It doesn’t
take a philosophy major to see the religious
undertones in all of this.
The covenant worship the forerunners—an
ancient alien race that constructed the Halo rings
The Covenant believe these rings were constructed for them as the chosen people.
or “reclaimers” of the forerunners mantel…
Only by activating the rings will their people
achieve eternal salvation.
With humanity, the covenant are confronted
with a race of people that make a similar
claim to ascension and access to the divine.
When confronted with an ideology in direct
opposition of their own there are a few options—the
Covenant can accept that there are multiple claims to the truth or they can exterminate
any threats to their faith.
Connolly uses the term “Exclusive humanism”
to describe the belief that people have when
they assert that they have the god market
cornered and everyone else can literally go to hell.
The interplanetary war in Halo starts with an attack on a human colony planet called
Harvest, where the Covenant attackers proclaim, "Your destruction is the will of the gods
and we are their instrument.”
Promised “The Great Journey” by the covenant
prophets—the covenant elites, brutes, jackals,
and other mobs fall in line and start blowing
shit up. It turns out isn’t so much salvation
as it is a cosmic death trap but that’s
neither here nor there.
When you take in to account the clearly deliberate
names “Harvest” and “The Great Journey,”
all this starts to sound less like religious
fundamentalism and more like Manifest Destiny-
or the idea behind the “civilizing” missions
of early Colonial America.
“Harvest” is reminiscent of early colony
life—the harvest of crops, thanksgiving,
and the pilgrims that originally came to America
are all part of the sort of story book version
of American settlement that we were taught
in grade school. When in reality, it was anything
but a great journey or a children’s tale.
“The Great Journey” is salvation promised
only for the advanced. For the covenant, the
human race is primitive, and can’t ascend—they
aren’t promised salvation.
This language of primitivism versus the rational
or civilized goes all the way back to Descartes-
Basically, it’s easier to subjugate and
entire population when they are reduced to
a status less than human—as inferior.
Similar to the dynamic between the humans
and the Covenant, The construction of American
Sovereignty—of national identity creation-
comes partly from the displacement, assimilation,
and eradication of the native cultures of
North America. Stripping of land rights from
the Natives was justified in part through
the dehumanization of their people—they
were uncivilized savages, primitives, brutes,
heathens—not people.
The major event that frames Halo is the fall
of Reach—a human colony laid to waste by
the Covenant. By following a UNSC ship named
“the Iroquois,” the covenant are able
to find Reach. Iroquois ought to sound familiar,
it's a native American nation that was part
of the “Seven Year’s War” or “the
French and Indian War” (to Americans).
There’s some Irony here in naming a ship
intended to facilitate space colonization
after an indigenous nation. In fact, a kind
of strange historical reversal takes place—the
UNSC, with their space marines serve as a
sort of extension of American colonialism—and
yet, the very same fleet positions itself
as the colonized victim of the covenant.
If, as Connolly says, identity is constructed
through differentiating ourselves from others,
then mixing imagery from religious extremism and Manifest Destiny is perhaps the peak
of irony for the creators. For the otherness the west fears in religious, specifically,
Islamic Fundamentalism is not only embodied in the covenant but also in our very own history
of colonization.
The idea that there would be a game
where you're forced to kill innocence.
Where the enemy is a blameless victim
probably wouldn't sell many units.
Or maybe it would.
While the first person shooter genre inevitably creates shallow characters
to be eliminated, disintegrated, and eradicated.
What Halo presents is the exploration that the enemy, the alien, the other
is not so different than we pretend.
Hey everyone, thanks for watching.